how about this we have this tweet from
poster tubs who says spencer cox the
republican governor of utah is now
officially using the term latinx le tinx
in government documents you can't make
this up
and here you can see it says um it just
says latinx here's the best part take a
look at this from this is from stl
tribune
conservative group shares misleading
video of utah governor spencer cox
listing his pronouns the zoom call was
part of a town hall with high school
students last spring
say in april 21 zoom call of spencer cox
republican listing his pronouns during a
town hall for high school students has
spread on social media after a
conservative group shared an edited
version of it how is that misleading
it's literally him sharing his pronouns
they go on to say the original 30 minute
zoom call was part of the one utah
student town hall held last year where
utah high school students asked the
republican governor questions about the
state's kova 19 response the edited
video makes it appear the governor
listed his pronouns right after
introducing himself the statement is
followed by the added sound of a sad
trombone during the town hall one
student from tuacan high school for the
arts in irvine uh in irvines listed her
pronouns when called upon to ask the
governor a question
she then asked what his plans were to
boost mental health services in schools
citing a survey that found gay and
lesbian youth face a higher risk for
depression well thank you so much for
that question and my preferred pronouns
are he him so thank you for sharing
yours with me how is it misleading to
show that he literally did that he did
right because any like
any real republican would just be like
okay and then not list their pronouns
right uh misleading sorry again this is
a new redefinition misleading is
something that makes a progressive look
bad regardless of whether it's truthful
exactly right so like that used to be i
understand this actually has some
reasonable like heritage in english
common law it took a while before like
truth was a defense to libel claims
right like that was some yeah that was
actually alexander hamilton litigated
that case where he was the first or was
a lawyer who finally won the argument in
american courts that's like hey i guess
we have this first amendment now which
means that this idea that libel doesn't
that truth is not a defense to libel
that can't be right right so uh but that
you know it used to be i forget what the
exact exact term of it but but it's like
libel used to be just statements that
embarrass someone regardless of whether
or not they're true and you could sue
for that yeah you could sue for that
right before this before like before
really before the constitution even in
the united like colonial united states
got rid of that i hope people like
effectively people could happen again we
could find ourselves in a in a medieval
situation where you get thrown in prison
for insult what someone else receives is
it that's crazy that's where we're going
shout out to alexander hamilton right
yeah great guy people people really you
know i'm a big hamilton guy as opposed
to a jefferson guy like hamilton
actually like saw what you know
jefferson basically wanted us to be an
agrarian slave society uh like you know
i mean he didn't like slavery that much
but he wanted that and hamilton was the
guy who's like no actually you know we
should we should have a a really
powerful country
in general like america should be strong
well so going back to the main story
though this is just another
very common and typical erosion among
republicans who give in immediately
because they're spineless yeah no i mean
i usually joke that namely name a more
useless republican than mitt romney
right who's
uh i love that tweet because everybody
engages with it and lists more useless
republicans
so um but yeah like utah what's going on
with utah guys like you're this is a red
red state and we have this whack a
whack-a-doodle liberal governor and a
whack-a-doodle rhino senator
yeah also get your stuff together
imagine
insulting yourself
on that level being a man
but telling people that you expect to be
referred to as he him as if they
wouldn't otherwise know what a
ridiculous cell phone
i i would if like i was in a situation
where for whatever reason they were like
you have to list your pronouns i would
absolutely just make up some really long
and ridiculous word and be like do it or
don't the fascinating thing about
pronouns is it's like
it comes out when you're not there right
how often do you're like oh he and like
they're not in the world it's like you
the only reason you use third-person
pronouns is because you're not talking
to that person right right so it's like
you want to control how i think about
you when you're not here
that's the craziest thing which is
you're right you're actually doing
violence against me you don't think
about me the way i want to be thought of
you know ezra miller the flash in the dc
cinematic universe or whatever or
whatever it's called
uh ezra miller came out as non-binary so
all the news articles say they them and
it's like you're butchering the english
language but it's not even that like
ezra miller as my understanding is not
trans
like just came out and said you have to
call me they them they're like okay
like
i understand
if there's an argument for a trans woman
who is overtly passing and
it was like what ben shapiro was saying
about blair it would be very difficult
or take a long time to explain why he'd
use a male pronoun for blaire white in
public to his friends so he would just
say she her it's the easiest way to go
about things but in you know literary or
in in articles he would say he him and
i'm like i understand that point i
understand why it is simpler just to
refer to someone as she her if they're
overtly feminine or he him for a trans
man who's overly masculine like buck
angel for instance but when we're
talking about some you know some guy
who's like i'm non-binary but he's still
just a regular
you know young man
you can't just tell people i have to
refer to you in a certain way you don't
own that that you're you exist outside
of i i exist okay you exist over there
i've never seen you and yet i'm supposed
to refer to him by pronouns and never
met the guy well i don't know if you
know this tim but as it turns out you
get to define your identity without
anyone around you having to consent to
it even though by definition your
identity is how you fit into the group
that you're interacting with human
society yeah it's like the group that
you're interacting with has absolutely
no say in how you're perceived it's
completely all up to you and if they
disagree with that they're just mean
until realism kicks in and the ukrainian
government's turning trans women back
that can't because they're actually men
and that are now trans women are they
converted uh we need that we need the
strong muscle on the front i don't care
how you identify yeah there's always
something interesting like there's
sometimes they the [ __ ] like pro trans
lobby if you will points to certain
societies say look there's an example of
of of you know how the society's
recognized trans people and it's like
the reason for that particular society
is because they're so homophobic that
the only way that you can dj is if you
transition in ukraine a
female to male transgender person
dressed up in women's clothing and then
crossed the border to escape
because i guess now
identifying as a woman she didn't want
to go
to war
and because of hormone therapy presented
hormone therapy presented as male and
would get stopped at the border and then
sent to go fight i find that fascinating
then you have basically no matter what
the circumstances that you have trans
women and trans men just trying to
justify escape from the country in
whatever way they can the trans women
are like but i'm actually uh you know a
woman so i should be allowed to leave
but they're not letting me and the trans
man is like time to dress up like a
woman and same woman so i get i can get
out of here
like if you want to be a man that comes
with the pros and the cons of being a
man conscription has always been one of
them but you know this is one of the big
things that uh we saw in the turn of the
century with suffrage movement there the
women who opposed it were like we don't
want male responsibilities in our lives
which include i believe like the fire
brigade was one issue in some areas
if you had having the right to vote
meant that you'd you'd be called upon as
a man to fight the fire brigade and they
believed they could be drafted that was
something that they feared right
and they will be
yeah because if we have a draft if we
ever have a draft again people are just
going to identify as women to get out of
the draft it'll be an easy form of draft
that's a very good point
so you'll very quickly have to start
drafting women too did you hear about
what's going on was it pasadena where is
it where they're going to be giving um
ubi to people who are non-binary yeah
yeah so this i was just thinking about
that and i was going to bring it up
i think this is a brilliant bill for our
cause frankly because they're only
allocating about 200 000 to this program
which means they're going to run out
very quickly
and it's impossible to define non-binary
because it's it's a non-existent
meaningless term so a bunch of people
are going to say they're non-binary to
get the money and it's going to run out
extremely quickly and people are going
to see how ridiculous the it's just
going to be another demonstration of how
nonsensical the modern gender theory bs
is
man i was my dad was a fireman growing
up and we when i went to the fire
department in some of the early 90s i
think it was like 12 or 13 and there was
a woman that worked there and i was like
hey how come there's a girl that's a
fireman and he was like oh she because
women can be firemen too and i was like
well why wouldn't she be called a
firewoman he's like no they're all
called firemen and then when i went to
college it was like yeah we're all
actors men and women we're all
considered actors we don't use the word
actress it's ridiculous so i got it i
mean it doesn't really care matter what
you call it it's more about who you are
and i was like can you how did can she
carry the heavy equipment and he's like
no she works in the death at the desk
but i it not that she couldn't carry the
heavy equipment she trained for it but
it was more about like less what you
call yourself and more what you actually
are that's what it comes down to when
the
when the crap hits the fan my friends
i've never really cared about you know
the words people use to describe me
it's the weirdest thing that people are
like you have to use someone's pronouns
or else but we're going to insult you
and call you names all day and night
like no no no you can't insult me i have
dictated the words you must use to
describe me that bill's successful
remember
what's the thing yeah it's violence and
abuse to misgender someone to not use
the proper pronouns but to try to have
secret conversations with children about
sexually depraved behaviors that's not
grooming right dude isn't it illegal in
canada to do that now bill
c-16 and then they passed another one
that jordan peterson was talking about i
didn't look into it yet but apparently
like if you misuse someone's pronouns it
can be a hate speech crime
this is this is insane
hopefully i'm not miscal if i'm
miscalculating this let me know in the
super chats or something yeah no there's
a there's some bill in canada that's
like dictating independent media or
whatever i think jordan peterson was
tweeting about it they want to control
what uh reporters and people with large
media platforms can say
that's where it's all headed because you
saw what uh the ceo of twitter said
years ago that we have to it's about
it's not about free speech it's about
how the times are changing and we have
to create a healthy conversation and
it's just like
these people are definition megalomaniac
sociopath psychos all that stuff my
worldview is the only worldview my
worldview is moral and justin everyone
must adhere to the way i see things that
is psychotic behavior and sometimes the
way we see things they'll do that cult
thing where it's like me and a bunch of
other weirdos that have my same
mentality so we are stronger in numbers
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there is a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm we'll see you all there